welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Miriam L hey Tommy a visiting scholar
who was at Yale as the rice fellow in
the Council on Middle East Studies at
the Macmillan Center her research
explores the dynamics of female
religious authority and activism in
contemporary Morocco she has published
articles on the role of female
faith-based actors in shaping new forms
of religious leadership and activism in
Morocco today we'll talk with Professor
el Hitomi about women and Sufism in
Morocco
welcome professor al-khattab Thank You
Marilyn glad to be here so let's begin
with your paper it's called women and
Sufism religious expression and the
political sphere in contemporary
contemporary Morocco so tell us about it
so the article basically explored gender
dynamics within morocco Sufi tradition I
examined the different styles of
participation a leadership within Sufi
orders and their complex relationship
with the public sphere I'm particularly
interested in the state's adoption of
Sufism as the official religious
discourse as part of its counter
radicalization strategy to shift toward
a more moderate practice of Islam one of
the arguments I make is that adopting
Sufism as as an official religious
discourse provides contributes to
providing a broader role for women and
increases their visibility and presence
within the public religious sphere and
also presents women's Sufi experience as
a well structured enterprise that
constitutes an element within the
broader scope of women's engagement with
religious knowledge authority and
activism another arguments I make is
that the mainstream in of sufism with in
Morocco's formal structures of Islam
disrupts the binary between official
religion that is associated with formal
structures of Orthodox or legal Islam as
opposed to popular or informal religion
that is oftentimes associated with
Sufism and constructs the tradition as a
heterodox or folkloric practice within
Islam a complicate in this binary allows
us an understanding of the different
realms of women's religious expression
and the ways they engage religious
authority and activism in the article I
also draw on hagiographical literature
to explore the traditional patterns of
female spirituality I am interested in
the conjunctures of tradition and
modernity and the continuity of Sufism
as a postmodern reality and how that
shifts the dynamics of female spiritual
expression okay let's start with the
word Sufism tell us what that is exactly
so Sufism is generally defined as
Islamic mysticism or the spiritual or
esoteric dimension of Islam that
incorporates techniques by which a
person seeks a direct or a personal
encounter with the divine what kind of
techniques it's like its devotional
practices it's kind of like meditation
okay so does it vary dramatically from
Islam
so-so so basically it is it is it is a
tradition within this law okay so by the
11th or 12th centuries Sufism that
started as a spiritual movement
developed into organizational structures
currently known as Sufi orders or
their hoods and these structures have
over periods of history served as major
scholarly and spiritual centers of
edification within Islam and have had
major social and political roles
so basically Sufism is oftentimes cast
as a as the quietest or disengaged
practice of a group of the marginal and
group of God's seekers
however place in Sufism within the
broader and varied contexts of the
Islamic tradition reveals that Sufis
have actually produced complex systems
of thought and elaborate interpretive
traditions and that the Sufi tradition
embraces a whole range of political
social institutional hermeneutical
literary aesthetic features within the
Islamic tradition and this understanding
of the Sufi tradition also helps us to
situate women's roles within the broader
or the complex discursive formations of
religious authority in Islam okay so how
did you become involved in doing this
kind of work what led you to it
so first because of my academic interest
and the forums of and changes of female
Islamic authority but I've been
interested in this particular topic
because Moroccan women's historical
participation in Sufism has received
very little scholarly attention okay the
primary sources that we have for these
roles and practices are basically
historical or hagiographic accounts
where of course male subjectivity is
dominate and especially that these works
are written by men so there's little
space that is devoted for women's
spirituality
there's also anthropological cities and
Travel literature or accounts and these
usually have Orientalist motives and
have contributed largely to constructing
the binary of official or formal Islam
that is male rational legal as opposed
to popular or informal Islam that is
female irrational and and spiritual so
there there is there is some lost
narrative there that needs to be
retrieved
thankfully a recent scholarship has
started food has started to account for
the nuances and the differences within
women's religious and spiritual
expression another motive is of course
personal as a person of faith who seeks
to fit in some form of spiritual space
and navigates the complexity of the
experience I do believe in the
importance of claiming and narrative
that tends to be unheard in the loud
rhetoric surrounding the woman question
and the dominant discourses that tend to
that tend to define women social roles
and Muslim contacts so talk about the
field work you did to do this paper so I
conducted ethnographic fieldwork for the
period of three years or even more
because of my personal interest in the
tradition so the purpose of this
fieldwork was to investigate women's
participation within Sufi orders and how
this participation both complicates and
sustains perceptions of the gender space
and the gendered practice of spiritual
authority so it was very interesting to
look at the
the discrepancies between the commonly
held belief that women are excluded from
positions of leadership and public
performance and how these women get to
define leadership and public performance
so I conducted fieldwork within
different Sufi orders and across
different regions and the country so it
was very fascinating to see that women
participate in significant numbers and
the tradition and that the tradition
itself is diverse and that there exists
multiple models of participation and
leadership and and and that there are
several avenues for women to practice
Authority and get recognized as
spiritual authorities so women
participate in communal and devotional
practices there are a lot of women who
serve as representatives of main male
authorities within their Sufi orders so
they oversee communal activities and
they determined the affiliation of
future adherence there's so many women
who serve as spiritual teachers although
women's spiritual leadership is excluded
in formal hierarchies within Sufi orders
but they're there a lot of women who are
recognized as spiritual authorities by
their followers and disciples both men
and women and I was also interested to
study these patterns in parallel with
fieldwork I conducted with sponsored
Imams and women activists within
Islamist movements and just observed
that these religious trends are not
homogeneous but they're not entirely
divergent either and this really helps
us understand the Islamic tradition and
women's roles within the tradition
beyond
essentialist and monolithic perception
very interesting so in Sufism is their
gender equality between men and women
well because it is a spiritual realm
where there is a strong argument that
there's absolute equality between men
and women because it's Sorrell where
only souls are recognized but not social
or biological differences but of course
the tradition is shaped by
socio-cultural circumstances so what are
you finding it's it's not homogeneous as
I said I conducted fieldwork in
different regions of the country where
you of course get different cultures as
well so there are settings that are more
welcoming and open to women and actually
and basically offer equal space for both
men and women like I attended communal
gatherings where I would be the only
woman and I would be seated in the same
space as the man and I would be served
tea and food by the men and so I've been
into those very welcoming and equal
spaces but I'll let you go to other
places where of course the culture is
more conservative and and I think it's
also it's also due to the fact that big
Sufi orders have have sort of structure
as to where men get to choose to have
their own space and conduct and oversee
their own activities so so okay all
right so what then are some of the
interactions between Sufism and politics
in Morocco
well the contested relationship between
Sufism and the states in Morocco's as
oldest and some Moroccan history over
periods of history
some Sufi orders have challenged
political authorities manifested
political ambition and established
connections with colonial powers while
other Sufi orders demonstrated absolute
support to the state in Morocco's recent
history especially in the context of of
the country's engagement and
counter-radicalization strategies after
the country was hit by a major terrorist
attack back in 2003 Sufi orders
re-emerged on the scene as a new and
powerful social and political force and
established a massive recruitment across
different social categories and among
both men and women so Sufism is
currently promoted as a tolerant
peaceful and apolitical
form of religiosity and which is the
opposite of excuse me yes yeah and and
it is exactly and it is enjoying great
super great state support because for
the very reason that it's considered as
a non oppositional religious trend
Sufism is also heavily promoted in the
media local and international
conferences and Sufi music festivals
organized all over the country to spread
and intellectualize debate about Sufism
and carriage aesthetic aesthetic
performance in 2011 Sufi or Sufi orders
emerged back on the scene as a
significant player in the context of the
Arab Spring uprisings so after King
Mohammed the six responded to popular
protests by drafting a modified
constitution Sufi orders urged their
followers to march in large numbers
industries in support of the new
constitution and the monarchy and this
shows the close interactions between
religion and politics in Morocco and
also serves to reiterate Morocco's sufi
oriented religious identity and
counterbalance oppositional voices
included in the growing as long as two
movements now you mentioned that women
can enjoy some form of leadership
through Sufism does that cross over into
these you know the secular world in
terms of politics do you see more women
because of their role in Sufism becoming
more have more leadership roles in
politics for instance well the political
sphere in Morocco is or the public
sphere in Morocco is a very
heterogeneous sphere so you get
different players and actors you have
political actors that include both as
long as in secular actors and you have
formal religious structures that now
include Sufism so you get different
players who have been performing in the
public sphere since the earlier history
of Morocco
especially after independence so I
personally what I find interesting is
that the institutionalization of certain
forms of Islam has contributed to
providing more visibility to certain
female actors but of course women have
been active in the public sphere since
earlier right right but I what I think I
was trying to get at because Sufism is
supported by the state do you see more
women more sufi women becoming more
active in the political parts of morocco
you see what I'm saying
you mean within the mainstream political
yeah yes yeah not in that sense because
Sufism presents itself as an apolitical
form of religious expression so it's not
a movement that would preach involvement
in political structures although
interestingly enough it can show up on
the political sphere to support the
states when necessary right but you
don't you don't really get Sufis aren't
carriage - part of the political parties
or or participate visibly actively
within the formal political sphere
although these spaces do overlap and
Sufism it's not this this this really
disengaged in a political religious
expression but it does interact with
politics in different ways okay so what
do you conclude in your paper well I I
don't know if I have a conclusion in my
paper this paper was just just sort of a
beginning in this research and it has
inspired me to do more research on this
yet uncharted terrain of research
basically so I hope to spend some of my
time here at Yale to work on pre-modern
sources and hagiographies of Sufi women
to sort of create a it sort of
constructs a historical narrative of how
gender operated and pre-modern in modern
Sufis or circles in Morocco I am
interested in recovering patterns of
women's spiritual expression and modes
of religious authority and
how that informs contemporary Sufi
practices well very interesting thank
you so much for being here with us today
I'm sharing some of your work thanks for
having me for more information about
Professor L Hitomi and her research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale.edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the Macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
you